welcome back dr nash has been
transforming lives
all across the valley and today she
joins us to share some
incredible success stories dr nash i am
so happy that you're on the show with us
today because
many of us are still focusing on our new
year's resolutions and for a lot of
people that is
to lose weight and you have some
inspiring stories for us today let's
talk about the first success story and
that first success story is
you you lost 80 pounds over 12 years ago
you still have kept it off you look
beautiful how did you do it
yeah so i actually struggled with my
weight ever since i was eight years old
and so from the time i was eight until
about 2009 when i learned this
information
i probably went on about three dozen
different diets all of them giving me
lackluster results
but in 2009 when i found out that there
are underlying issues that drive
the weight gain outside of calories and
activity that's when i was able to lose
the 80 pounds but more important than
that
able to keep it off eating two to three
thousand calories a day and that's what
we do for our clients now
and let's talk about some of your
clients we're gonna talk about catherine
first let's show the video of catherine
i went from a size 14 to a size six in
30 days
i no longer suffer from fibromyalgia and
i no longer suffer from depression
she was suffering from a lot of
depression because she suffered the loss
of a child
right which could wreck anybody her
weight ballooned up after that she
couldn't crawl out of it
she started seeing these other problems
like fibromyalgia she decided she wanted
to change her life she came to us
we were able to identify that the
fibromyalgia was coming from
inflammation she was also struggling
with a dietary hormone problem
when we were able to fit the right
program to her she had she went from a
size 14
to a six in 30 days amazing stories
the next one to look at here is this is
laura when i started with dr nash i
weighed over 300 pounds and i was
pre-diabetic
since being on a program i lost over 130
pounds
and i no longer have that pre-diabetic
threat she really thought that it was
menopause that was driving her weight
problems so she came to us hoping we
would fix her menopause weight gain
but it wasn't menopause she did have a
hormone problem but it wasn't
sexual hormones it was dietary but she
also had something called
fatty liver disease so when we were able
to help her with both of those issues
she went on to lose 130 pounds look at
sarah's results
in just three short months of losing
weight i've lost 52 pounds and 35 inches
off my waist which is where i wanted it
most
sarah was going to school to become a
nurse right so she was actually medical
training
she was also working for me but she kept
seeing all of these people having
amazing results so she asked if she
could do it too
and she did she went on she lost about
50 pounds under the program but because
we gave her the tools to keep it going
she went on to lose a staggering 98
pounds now great thing about you is
every time you come on las vegas now
you bring a really cool special what do
you have for us this week normally to do
the evaluation to find out if you have
these issues and if i can help you
that's 97
but if you mention that you saw me on
las vegas now with jc then we have 10
spots available where we're going to do
it for a reduced price
the first step in that reduced price is
the 997 evaluation
over 90 off but you can only get it
through the website address that we're
going to be flashing on the screen so
make sure you jump in on that
you get that evaluation find out if i
can help you and get it fixed for good
again the las vegas now special offer
9.97 it's normally 97.
call 702-852-6888 or visit dr nash dot
com
forward slash eval your evaluation will
be done online
for your safety